[MUSIC PLAYING]
GOBIND JOHAR: My name is Gobind.
I am a product at Google.
I work on cloud networking
and GKE networking.
With me, I have my
colleague, Ray Colline.
He's in the back
getting suited up.
I'll just introduce him.
Ray Colline is a senior
engineer at Google,
software engineer at Google.
He thinks a lot about policy
management and multi cluster
stuff.
And you'll see some
of that awesome stuff
that him and his team
have worked on today.
The goal of this presentation
here is to really give you
an idea of three things
really-- like how to think about
security in a multi
cluster world--
that's one.
Second, you also want
to think about how
you can do high resolution
policy management using
Kubernetes and Istio, which are
at the heart of Anthos, which
you've heard a
bunch of this week.
And third, finally,
you'll understand
how to manage this
across all your clusters
without having to scale
your security budget.
So you can scale
your security posture
without having to really
spend too much money on it.
So, that's where
we're going with this.
And since it's a
Thursday afternoon,
we understand that it's
time to leave soon,
so we'll try to keep
it short and sweet,
and hopefully, give you the
most entertaining session
that we can.
Because it's security,
and who doesn't
want to listen to security
on a Thursday afternoon?
All right, just a
quick plug for Dory.
If you have questions, please
feel free to use our Dory app.
It's how we do Q&A
internally at Google.
It works really well.
We love it.
So give a shot.
If you have questions, we'll
be happy to get answers to you
before or after the session.
They'll save those questions.
So we'll be sure to get--
and also, there's mics,
so you can come up there.
You've already seen this
slide, but this is actually
more for me than it is for you.
I practiced this
presentation with CSP,
and then they changed
the name to Anthos
like two days before that.
So, now if I say
CSP, I mean Anthos.
It's all Anthos now.
OK, we've got the
housekeeping done.
So let's get into the contents.
The agenda for today,
we'll figure out
how Anthos puts a framework
around network security
and how we think about
what security means
in the multi cluster world, and
how defense and death really
applies to that
concept, which is
how we've figured
out that security
should work in the future.
We'll see how the different
layers of Anthos-- so
Kubernetes and Istio
specifically give you very high
resolution policy
management, which
you can use to
protect your clusters
at every layer of the system.
We'll see a demo where
Ray will step on up
and he'll show you how to do
this very effectively and very
quickly.
You'll probably never
go back to using stuff
that you're using today.
I love it, personal
bias-- sorry.
And then we'll talk about Anthos
Security Monitoring, which
is really important because once
you've deployed your policies,
you also want to
see them working.
So we'll talk about
how to do that.
And then we'll have
some closing thoughts.
Let's start with
Anthos core values.
So I don't know if you've
seen these before already,
but I just want
to level set here.
Modernizing in place is
a key pillar for Anthos.
What we're trying
to do is, for you
to be able to take advantage
of latest cloud tech
without having to leave
the comfort of your home.
Home, in this case,
being on-prem.
You don't have to move
through GCP or whatever
to take advantage of all
the great tech like GKE
and other things
we're working on.
So you can try this
on your on premises
and at your own comfort level.
And try to migrate over, if
that makes sense for you,
at your own pace.
That's the whole value
proposition of Anthos.
Another thing we
really care about
is automating policy at scale.
And why do we do that?
We've all owned or own
multiple smart devices
and they all fall out of sync.
And we've all seen that.
It's a huge problem.
And you can imagine if you
start having multiple Kubernetes
clusters or GKE clusters all
across the planet, let's say,
if they start falling
out of sync, that's
not a pleasant thought
for anyone, and especially
in security.
So we want to take that grunt
work out of the system for you
and we want to do it for you.
And that's where we'll
go with this as well.
We'll show you how that's done.
And ultimately, we
want to take all this
towards a consistent experience.
That's what really
we're doing here.
We want to build this
consistent system,
so that you only have
to build your tech once
and then you can
deploy it anywhere.
That's really important to us.
And automation is a
huge part of that.
Because it'll help
you be consistent.
Because obviously,
you don't have time
to keep learning all the
new tech as it comes out.
You have other
things to do as well.
So we want to make sure that
you get a consistent experience
using Anthos.
OK, just a quick 10,000 foot
view of what Anthos looks
like at a top surface.
There's a couple
of key things here.
I know there's a
few things going on,
so I'll just quickly
go over them.
Anthos control plane is
really your management plane,
where you can do things like
policy management, service
management, and
cluster management.
And the idea is, that for
you to be able to run on-prem
or in cloud, GCP, or
AWS, or whatever it is,
you can run there, but
you've only built this once.
And you can manage
it all centrally
from a single pane of glass.
And then the other most
more important thing,
which is more relevant
to this session
is thinking about security
from the ground up.
So when GKE and Istio
came up as projects,
security was a core
design principle
for all of these technologies
at every step of the way.
So it's a first class
citizen for security
to be part of these layers.
And that's what we
really want to talk
about in the next few
slides in this session.
Quick description of
why this slide is here.
So, we all have been doing
security for a long time.
And it doesn't-- we've been
doing it for a very long time,
ever since we started putting
computers on the internet,
but it's still a
really hard problem.
And the problem is, as
our security techniques
evolve, attacks evolve.
And then we're like, OK, it's
the chicken and egg problem
again.
We're still chasing
and trying to fix this.
So what do we do?
We can't build a one
size fits all solution,
every organization is
different, every company
has different needs, and
that's totally understandable.
And the hard-shelled
perimeter model, or I
think it's also called
the eggshell model,
it doesn't work
very well anymore.
Because we've seen examples
in the past where infiltrators
have been inside the company.
And that's not going
to work anymore.
So we take micro segmentation
at every layer very seriously.
And that's what we
think about security
as a defense in-depth model.
Also referred to
as the onion model,
which is why you see
that picture there.
And to relate that
onion model to Anthos,
we really think about Anthos
in three different layers
of infrastructure.
We think of them
starting at the bottom
of the pyramid with nodes.
We all know our VMs.
We love our VMs.
They're awesome.
And we've also protected
them in firewalls
for an eternity at this point.
So we're not going to
talk about firewalls.
And the next level up from
nodes is pods, Kubernetes pods,
which is somewhere in the
middle of nodes and services.
And then finally, at the
top we have Istio services
which is our new service mesh
that we're talking about.
So those are those three levels
that we're imagining Anthos as.
And we want to
think about security
at each of these layers to
give you a very strong defense
in-depth security posture.
It actually still
says that the clusters
are in California, Illinois,
North Carolina, and Texas.
So just imagine that you
had states mapped there.
So, I want to motivate the
example here a little bit more.
Because we're really talking
about a multi cluster now.
We've done one cluster.
We're now going out and
deploying multiple clusters
all around the country,
the globe, what have you.
And what we want to try to
do is understand what sort
of problems we get into
when we start talking
about security at this scale.
So imagine a retail bank.
I mean, this could
be retail anything.
A retail bank, it's
running on Anthos.
What that means is they've
deployed four unique GKE
on-prem clusters.
So they're all independent
standalone GKE clusters running
on premises in the branch.
And the idea there
is that the bank
has realized that real time
services for their customers
is super important.
So they've taken the step and
they've adopted GKE on-prem--
that's great.
And they've deployed
four for now.
They've gone to California,
Illinois, North Carolina,
and Texas.
So this is great, but now you're
already asking the question,
how do I keep these
things in sync?
Because you can change one
thing on one cluster, and then
suddenly, all of your other
clusters are out of sync.
That's not all.
Once that starts happening,
you have fleet fragmentation,
because your app's start
diverging in versions.
And the worst part of
it all is that leads
to all your development teams
adopting a different workflow
for production and deployment.
And that is a security
nightmare for every one of us.
So we want to prevent that.
Just to motivate the
example a bit more,
I want to show you what
they're running inside.
It's a simplistic example.
We've obviously curated
the details for you
to get the most out
of this session.
It could be a much
more complex setup.
But imagine each cluster
is running three services
primarily-- account summary,
products, and PII database.
The idea here is that a teller
could come to the home page
and look up a customer's account
summary by making a request.
And the account summary can
get access to PII database.
The product service, or any
other service, for that matter,
should not be able to
get to the PII database
under any circumstances.
So, that's our sort of
setup for this problem.
And we're going to
work through this step
by step to see how we can
use all the layers of Anthos,
namely Kubernetes and Istio,
to protect this and get
the posture that we want.
OK, network policy--
how many of you
have heard of network policy?
Kubernetes Network Policy?
OK, maybe like a fourth, or
maybe a third of the room,
maybe.
OK, so that's good.
Why do we need it?
So, we have pods, that I
told you about earlier.
Pods, when you deploy Kubernetes
pods today in your system,
by default they can
talk to anything.
This can be a good
thing and a bad thing,
depending on how
you're looking at it.
From a developer's
point of view,
it's awesome,
because you can get
access to whatever you want.
From a security
person's point of view,
it's not cool,
because you need to be
able to lock it down and make
sure that the surface area is
protected.
So keeping that in mind, we have
this feature in Kubernetes--
it's OSS.
We fully support
it in GCP and GKE.
So you can think of it as
a firewall for your pods,
of sorts.
What it does is, it cuts down
any sort of restricted traffic
out of the system.
So your pods can never
go out and do stuff
that you don't want them to do.
So that's the idea behind this.
You can express rich ingress and
egress rules using this APII.
You can actually write IP
addresses and sider blocks
if you choose to.
I recommend not.
You can do that though.
You can use Kubernetes labels.
And you can also use
Kubernetes namespaces.
So that's awesome, because
it's a first class citizen.
And finally, if you're already
using namespaces in Kubernetes
to support your
workloads and keep
them grouped and
separated, in some sense,
logically, you can use
Kubernetes Network Policy
really easily, as it is
a namespace property.
So it applies to all your pods
within the namespace instantly.
So that's really, really cool.
All right, so let's bring
it back to the example
that we looked at earlier.
We had our account summary
service, we had products.
And our mission was we
don't want any other service
except for account
summary service
to be able to talk
to the PII database.
So here, I've set
up a simple policy,
a network policy object.
It's missing a few details, but
the key things are highlighted.
What we're trying
to do here is we're
trying to select the
PII database pods.
So I want to emphasize
the fact here
that we're selecting pods here.
We're not talking about
services just yet.
We're talking about pods.
We're still in the middle
of the VMs and services.
So we're at pods.
So we're selecting
our PII database pods.
And what we're
doing is, the moment
we implement a network policy
selecting the PII database
pods, all the traffic is
cut from PII database.
So the PII database pods
cannot go out to the internet,
cannot go to other
services or other pods.
Other pods can't come
to the PII database.
It's a purely white list model.
So a white list model means
you have to explicitly now tell
the system what traffic is
allowed to come to PII database
or go from the PII database.
So the words we use for that
is ingress and egress, which
I'm sure all of you
are very familiar with.
So just to sort of summarize
that the comment, the moment
you create a network policy
object, and you select
all the PII database pods,
all the communication,
all network traffic, is cut
off from them immediately.
Now you go take the
next step, and you
say, OK, I want to allow
ingress from account summary
to PII database.
So, you say, OK, well,
I'm going to select
all the pods that are running
accounts summary service.
And I'm going to let them
talk to PII database.
That's great.
And that actually
solves our problem here.
So we've talked about ingress,
but I left out the egress part
just yet.
So you can actually either
mention the egress keyword here
or leave it out completely.
Because as I mentioned earlier,
by putting it under a policy,
you've already cut
traffic from it entirely.
So it's a white list model.
If you do not enable
explicitly any egress sources,
no traffic is leaving your pods
and you can be sure of that.
All right, we're
moving a level up now.
So we've talked about
our pods, that's great.
We've secured them at a lower
level of the infrastructure,
that's fantastic.
We've cut our service area.
We know for sure
that the IP traffic
we don't want to reach the
pods is not reaching them,
that's awesome.
But now, we need to start
thinking about our services.
So, who here has already heard
about Istio security policy.
Almost the same
fraction of people.
Not the same people, the
same fraction of people.
OK, so what we're
going to try to do
is just-- actually, how many
of you have heard of Istio,
and understand what
Istio is almost?
OK, good.
I'll try to just--
I came up with a cool analogy.
I think it's cool--
I'm biased-- I'm sorry.
I'll give you a cool analogy
to how I understand Istio.
So imagine you're a host at
a birthday party with lots
of children running around.
These children
are microservices.
And you're trying to protect
them from getting hurt.
So if you can actually strap
balloons and stuff across
everybody, that would
be great, but you can't.
There's too many
kids running around.
You can't do that.
So you can imagine Istio coming
in and helping you there,
and saying, OK, I'm
going to let you control
these microservices, because
luckily microservices
are easier to control than
kids are at a birthday party.
But yeah, that's my analogy.
Feel free to use
it if you want to.
That's where we're
going with this.
So to control all your
Istio microservices,
you need to put security
policies in place.
What do we have here?
So we, first of all,
start with strongly
authenticating all our
services, as well as our users.
So Istio by itself
issues strong identities,
and strong non-mutable
identities,
to each service that's
running inside your mesh.
So this is great, because we'll
talk about the next point here
in a moment.
But this is great because
it's non-mutable identities.
You don't have to lift
a finger for this.
Istio does it for you
right off the bat.
And users are also
authenticated by the system,
but the identity is not issued.
We'll touch on that
in more detail later.
So let's keep going.
Encryption for everyone--
so, because we've
authenticated everybody
in the system,
including users,
including services,
we can use that identity
to encrypt and establish
an MTLS channel between all
your traffic within the mesh.
So you can get service
to service encryption
for basically free, without
having to change anything.
And context based
authorization--
so we've done authentication,
we've done encryption.
But we also want to
do authorization,
because we want to make
sure that only certain parts
of the system are accessible
and certain parts are completely
off access.
Because, really, access is
really a non-binary thing.
It's more of in a spectrum.
Some people have access
to certain things,
some people have
access to other things.
So we're going to look at how
to do partial access as well.
OK, going back to our example--
let's start with authentication.
In this case, I've set
up a simple example.
Again, these are some of
the most common examples I
see when people have questions.
So there's more details.
If you keep reading
more, and more, and more,
you'll get very excited
about security, as I do.
But here, I've taken a simple
example of user authentication.
What's happening here is
we're using a policy object,
Istio policy object
here, and we're
selecting the PII
database service,
in this case-- not pods,
we've moved up a layer.
So this is the Istio--
the PII database is
the Istio service
that we're targeting here.
And we're selecting it
under this policy object.
And we're saying
only let users who
have jot tokens issued by
Acme.com access this service.
So jot tokens, if
people are familiar,
they're a common OIDC
protocol implementation.
And a lot of times it could
be Active Directory, or OCTA,
or any other provider like that.
But Istios uses
jot the time being.
And in this case,
you could provide--
assign a token from
Acme.com, and the system
will let you through,
which is great.
Because if it was
coming from Fakeme.com,
it won't be allowed access.
Encryption in
transit-- so, we've
done identity, that's awesome.
How do we take it from there
to giving you encryption?
Well, you don't
have to do anything.
The system does it for you.
How does it do it?
We have a little thing called
Envoy, a sidecar proxy that's
part of this Istio bundle.
The Istio bundle
installs the Envoy proxy
in front of all of
your microservices.
And every time
you have a service
that wants to talk
to another service,
if you enable this policy--
so in this case,
what we're doing is
the PII database service is
being targeted by this policy,
and it's saying all my
peers should use MTLS
while talking to me.
The curly brackets there
not specifying a service
means all services.
So what this does is, it
forces all of the people
or all of the services
that are trying
to talk to PII database
ensure that they MTLS enabled
or encryption enabled.
The one thing I
didn't show here is--
it's called the
destination rule.
Ray will briefly touch
upon that in his demo,
to show you how
account summary can
start talking to PII
database using MTLS
by setting a destination
rule after this policy.
Authorization-- so we've
done two things so far.
We've prevented untrusted
access to the system
and we've prevented man
in the middle attacks.
But that's not sufficient.
As I mentioned earlier,
a lot of times your users
have partial access
to the system.
They don't have full
access to the system.
So how do you go
about doing that?
So, in our little
example here, I
want to allow tellers to only be
able to read the PII database,
but not write anything
to the database.
So what we're going
to do here is,
we're going to set up a
service roll call PII viewer.
And what that role
is doing here is,
it's granting get permissions
to the PII database.
So the get would be the
HTTP equivalent of read.
And when you associate
that service role
with a service role binding, and
in that service role binding,
what you're specifying
is that the access has
to come from accounts
summary, and it
has to come from a
group called tellers.
So that group is actually
coming from the jot token
that I mentioned earlier.
These are details you can read
about more if you wanted to
or I'm happy to answer questions
afterwards if you have any.
But the idea here is that
you're very clearly specifying
in your authorization
policy what
is allowed to access
your PII database service
and what is not.
And only the tellers
group can do a read here.
So we've talked about
several policies already.
And I want to show a picture
of how they all fit together
and how they work in
harmony, so to speak.
This is the path we really want.
We want a user at Acme.com
or a teller at Acme.com
to be able to access
account summary
and be able to get
to PII database.
So we lock down the access from
PII database to the internet,
and we lock down any other
service, any other pods,
from being able to
reach the PII database.
So we cut that out first.
That was our first network
policy object that we created.
It locked down access from
products to PII database.
We also cut out
access to internet.
So PII database, if it had
any faulty code or anything
and it inadvertently tried
to go to the internet,
that's all cut out also.
Then we went into
off authentication.
We cut out access
from Fakeme.com
and any other
websites that might
be issuing tokens and trying
to access your system.
We enabled encryption, so
that account summary and PII
database are always talking
on an encrypted channel.
So that none of your man
in the middle attacks
can actually steal
data from you.
We also cut down the HTTP post
request from user at Acme.com.
What we're trying to
do here is very clearly
draw a line between what's
allowed from the tellers group
and what's not.
And if the teller got
really clever here,
and tried to bypass
the account summary,
that would also be rejected.
So the only path left in
the system is this one.
And that's what we
just implemented
with three simple policies.
So I just want to just show you
the power of this sort of fly
by wire security system,
where you're doing everything
based on policy.
You're not configuring
firewalls anymore.
manual switches anymore.
This is moving above a layer.
And it's giving you a real
fly by wire experience,
because you can do all this
by setting a few policies.
And all of the fabric
will change according
to your requirements,
to give you
as high a micro segmentation
as you could possibly imagine.
Just to quickly distinguish
between the two policies
that we've talked about.
We've talked about
Kubernetes Network Policy.
Istio Security Policy.
You might be asking why
we have to use both.
The real answer is, they're
both good at really--
they're really good
at different things.
So Kubernetes Network Policy
is really good at cutting down
your attack surface area, while
Istio Security Policy gives you
fine grained access control
at the service level.
So you need the umbrella
and the raincoat
to protect you from the rain.
And now we have our demo.
Please welcome Ray.
RAY COLLINE: So hi everyone.
I'm Ray Colline.
I'm a software engineer.
And I work on Anthos
Config Management.
And today what we
want to do is take you
through a demo, which is going
to show a lot of the concepts
that Gobind just talked
about in his presentation.
And if you've
installed Istio, it
comes with an
example application,
which looks a lot
like the bank example
that Gobind just
said, or talked about.
So here we have a ratings app.
You can think of this
as the PII database.
You have a reviews system,
which you can think
of as like the account summary.
And then you have basically
a product page at the front.
End these three things
then get requests.
And then they're allowed to talk
to these different backends.
I'm also going to be demoing
Anthos Config Management
as a way to deploy
the Bookinfo app
and show it on two different
clusters at the same time.
So the idea here is,
if you're running
in two different
availability zones
or in two different
regions, you can
deploy this app using one
set of edits into a get repo.
And then those will propagate
off to each of the clusters.
And if you wanted to do
a progressive rollout,
you could insert a
cloud build pipeline,
which basically, each
cluster gets its config,
and then 10 minutes or an
hour later, it could go ahead
and get the other one.
And you could stick a canary
analysis service or something
else in between.
So, with that said,
let's go through
and kind of show
you the setup here.
So we have two clusters.
One is in US central one
and one is in US east four.
And these are just
really simple clusters.
You'll see currently,
on the URL here,
that there's nothing there.
And on here, there's
nothing there.
And when we switch over--
I'll go over here.
So what we'll see here is
we have, in this window,
is looking at all the
pods for cluster one.
Here, we're looking at all
the pods for cluster two.
And here, we're looking at
cluster two's service roles,
so these are policies.
And this here is
my get repo, local
get repo, where I'm going
to be making my changes
and pushing them.
Now this gets sent up to GitHub.
And GitHub is right
here, which you
can see also, if I refresh
it, has nothing in it.
It is just a blank
thing with system,
which is the default way.
So, these clusters, I've
installed the Istio Operator
and I've installed the Anthos
Config Management Operator.
And then I configured the
Anthos Config Operator as such.
So what we can see here is,
when we look at cluster one,
you'll see that it's
just a regular YAML
to configure Config Management.
And we give it a cluster name.
So amazingly, in
Kubernetes, there
is no cluster identity built in.
So we actually give
each cluster a name,
so we can refer
to it for purposes
of being able to target
policies at a given cluster.
We then tell it where to go.
So I'm telling it, hey, go to
GitHub, and go to this root
here.
And then I could
tell it which branch.
So I'm saying go to master.
And if you wanted to go to
canary, you could go to canary.
You could end up
creating a branch
and using the get
merge functionality
to push things along.
At this point, I'm
telling you to use SSH.
We support SSH and get cookies.
And I'm saying, hey, use this
root as the policy directory.
And that means you
can use one repo
and have different environments
in one repo if you want,
or you could have
different repos.
It's up to each
person or environment.
So anyways, I've installed
that on two clusters.
And so let's go.
At this point, what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to deploy
the Bookinfo app.
But I'm going to
deploy it insecurely.
So everything is plain text.
There's no security rules.
And everything can
talk to each other.
And so what you'll
see here is, I've
created a new
namespaces directory.
I've created a
Bookinfo namespace.
I've created the
namespace YAML, which
is the same one you
would kubectl apply.
I've created a Bookinfo
which has a set of services
and a set of deployments,
which map to the four
different services
that are said,
and a Bookinfo gateway,
which exposes it
to the outside of my cluster.
So at this point, I'm going
to go ahead and add this--
initial deployment and
then I'm going to get push.
So that gets pushed up.
And then we can do--
what we'll notice
on the right hand side is
these pods will start creating.
And there we go.
So cluster two picked it up.
And it's going ahead
and deploying the app
as we review this.
And then we have
that on cluster one.
So what's going on
in the background is,
there's an agent running
on each cluster that's
looking at that GitHub
repo I showed you earlier.
And it senses that there's
a new change in there.
And it goes ahead and pulls down
that stuff and kubectl applies
everything in that
repo automatically.
OK so, when we go
into namespaces,
you'll see here that these are
just everyday standard files.
So here we have a service.
Here we have a deployment--
service, deployment,
ports, et cetera--
OK, cool.
So with that said,
what we should see here
is our bookstore app.
And we have the details,
which is one service.
And we have the product page,
which is this overall page.
And we have the
book reviews, which
is comprised of two services.
One is the review and
one is the rating.
And you'll notice that
in the Bookinfo example,
there's three versions
of the ratings.
And if I refresh
this, you'll see
that we are doing Round Robin.
The network's not as fast here.
And these should change
over time, as in, this
is a different version.
And they're changing.
So this is showing us
that Istio routing.
And what you could do with
Istio, which is also cool,
which Gobind didn't
cover, is there's also
this idea of routing.
And so you can run multiple
versions at the same time.
And you could do traffic
shaping and traffic spreading,
and roll out 5%, 10%, et
cetera, to new versions,
to make sure that things are
happening, in addition to all
the security benefits.
OK, so now that we have this
deployed, it's insecure.
What we want to do is, we
want to layer encryption
on top of this.
So, we want all the pieces here,
instead of being plain text,
we want them to actually
have the nice little barrel
of encryption around them.
So, let's figure
out how to do that.
So, I go back here.
And what you'll notice is,
in the current images--
so, I've gotten all the
pods that are there.
are the images that
are running, which
is just the Bookinfo software.
As we stated earlier, is
that Istio has a sidecar
proxy that runs as a container.
And that gets injected
when you run your pods.
And that's where
the proxy happens.
And the way that the Docker
networking stack gets set up
is, we only allow
those pods to talk
to the proxy and nothing else.
So now, all ingress and egress
must transit through the proxy.
And that gives Istio--
that gives you the
security guarantees
that Istio gives you.
So let's do that.
So enable MTLS on each.
You'll see here that I ended
up with some extra files, which
I'll talk about
in a minute here.
And let's go ahead
and add some--
so we're adding some MTLS.
We're pushing that up.
Let's go look what
actually happened here.
When we go to Bookinfo and
we look now at the namespace,
you'll see here that
we have this comment
called Istio injection enabled.
And I'll do this, because
syntax highlighting is fun.
So we have Istio
injection enabled.
And what this says is,
anytime you create a pod,
go ahead and automatically
add the Istio sidecar
to that pod, the container,
the Istio proxy container
to that pod, and wire
it up so that they only
can talk through the proxy.
Cool.
Now, now that we
have that enabled--
oh, and we'll talk about
destination rules too,
which are fun.
So with destination rules,
what we're saying here
is, hey, if I'm going to go
ahead and talk to the product
page, I'm going to
use Istio mutual.
And that means that when
I talk outbound to egress,
I'm going to use--
and I want to talk to the review
service, I'm going to use MTLS.
And this is set
for all the things,
ratings reviews, details.
And this says, hey,
on those arrows,
go ahead and encrypt those
with MTLS when I talk.
And then the other
thing that we did here
is, at the cluster level,
when I go to cluster,
I have a mesh policy now.
Now, within CSP
Config Management,
when you have put things
in the cluster directory,
that gets pushed to the root
level of each cluster that's
being managed.
And so, now, cluster
one and cluster two
both have this mesh policy
that says the following.
It sets a default
policy and it says MTLS.
So it says any pods
in any namespace
must use MTLS to be talked to.
And so that helps you as
an administrator guarantee
that you're using MTLS.
Now what we're
going to notice here
is, because we've changed
the makeup of the pods, that
doesn't reconcile automatically.
And when we show
the current images,
we still have the
Istio Bookinfo.
So we need to restart the pods.
And so I'm going to show you
a feature of Anthos Config
Management, which is called--
which my co-worker facetiously
named Insistent Reconciliation.
And that means that, whatever
the state that's in the repo,
we guarantee that we make
the cluster that state.
So, if I destroy the
deployments, which
I defined in the repo,
the Anthos Config Manager
will automatically
recreate them.
So I'm going to go ahead
and kill those deployments.
And you'll see here that, here
they've gotten all deleted.
You'll see that you'll
have a bunch terminating.
And now you'll have a bunch
initializing at the same time.
And so that happened because
the Anthos Config Manager
wants the cluster to be
in the state of the repo
so we can have that guarantee.
So at this point,
what I'm going to do
is show the current images.
And what you're going to
see here is, three of them
have now picked up
the Istio proxy.
And then you have the
three that are terminating,
which will go away soon.
So now we have
Istio proxy sitting
in front of our existing pods.
We have told the
system to use MTLS.
We have encryption
across all setups.
So at this point,
what I should see
is, when I refresh this,
assuming everything is speedy,
is the Book app
should be working,
as is, which it looks
like it is-- sweet.
Except now, everything
is talking encrypted,
between all these
different points--
OK, cool.
So next step, now
they've got encryption,
what we want is the ability
to lock things down.
And we want to say,
you know what--
it's great that you
have encryption,
have authentication,
but now let's put some
authorization into the mix.
And we're going to start by
just turning on authorization,
but setting no policy,
so it's deny by default.
So, we're going to go ahead
and enable service Rbac.
End you'll see here that
we've got a cluster Rbac.
So let's go ahead and push that.
Get commit dash m, add
Rbac, and then get push.
So, when that goes
ahead and push,
let's go look at that
cluster Rbac policy
and see what it says.
So here we go.
We have a cluster Rbac config.
We have applied at
the named default,
so it's the root one for
all the whole cluster.
And it's saying, for this
namespace, please enforce.
And enforce is deny
by default, which
means you have to explicitly
list the Rbac service
binding in order for
things to talk to services.
And so now, this forces all
of the application writers
on your clusters to explicitly
detail their dependencies.
So in this case,
we're going to want
to be able to-- each one
of these things is going
to require rules, so product
page could talk to reviews,
and product page
could talk to details,
and reviews can talk to ratings.
So we push that.
We're saying it's enforced.
What I would expect to happen
here, now that we have that,
is the app should break.
And it has.
And you'll see here
that on both clusters,
I get Rbac access denied.
I tried to hit the product page.
When I hit there there,
it said there's Rbac.
There's no Rbac authorization
allowing my user
to get the product page,
so it said go away--
great.
So with that said, let's go
ahead and add a partial rule
to show how you can
add authorization
on a piecemeal basis.
So we're going to do--
adding an Rbac policy.
So you'll see here that we
got a namespace policy file.
We're going to go
ahead and add that--
partial policy, and get push.
So while that's going on--
and again, all this is
happening through Anthos Config
Management.
I'm not running kubectl at all.
It's all happening
behind the scenes.
When I go into the namespace,
there's extra credit
if people can realize
a couple of things
here about the security
aspects of these policies
end of the page.
I'll see if anyone
identified them at the end
and go from there.
So when we look at
this namespace policy,
you'll see here I have
a service viewer role.
And what I'm saying is,
is that all services--
so basically matching any
URL, any method, get--
and I'm saying
allow these apps--
product page in details
to talk to each other.
So I'm allowing the
product page to talk,
and I'm allowing people to
talk to the product page.
But the details are
being able to be
talked to by the product page.
But notice what's missing
here-- ratings and reviews.
And then down here, I
have a role binding,
which binds both the
Istio system namespace.
So it can get telemetry.
And the Bookinfo
namespace, which says,
hey, things running a
Bookinfo are allowed
to be given this role,
as long as they have
the constraints of the
destination labels,
being product and details.
So what we should notice now
is a partially working app
on both clusters.
And that's what we have.
We have the details.
We have the product page.
But we have no product reviews.
There's been an error, because
it's got in Rbac denied,
which will return as a 403.
OK, cool, great, we've been
able to partially do that.
Let's add the full--
and by the way, just to show
you that this is all real,
we have all these things
within the GitHub repo.
OK, so we're going to go
ahead and add the full service
Rbac policy.
And from there, we're getting--
OK, so that's pushing.
You notice, out here, we
have a service viewer policy
that just got pushed earlier.
With that said, let's look
at our namespace policy now.
You'll see that
we've added reviews
and we've added ratings.
So at this point, everything
is allowed to talk.
We have enabled that.
And so let's write that out--
cool.
That's been pushed earlier.
We should notice that
the app starts working.
And there it is.
And doing the right
thing through that.
So great, we've just
now gone back through.
We've started with
an empty cluster,
just with Istio and just with
Anthos Config Management.
We deployed the
Bookinfo app insecurely.
We layered on MTLS.
We added cluster Rbac policy
saying deny by default.
We layered on a couple
of different policies
to have the app be able
to talk to each other.
And at this point, we have
a fully kind of enabled Rbac
Istio application, that has
been working from the beginning,
from the insecure state, to
adding and layering on Istio.
And I never changed a line of
code in the Istio Bookinfo app.
And to finish it off, I'm
going to go ahead and remove
everything.
So that takes my
repo back to normal.
And then I'm just
going to push this.
So get add dash a,
get commit, dash m.
Kill all, and then I'm
going to push that.
And, as a final thing,
if I actually go up here,
what we will see is all of these
things will go to terminating.
They will remove the clusters,
because if they're not
in Anthos Config
Management, we go ahead
and we'll take them
out of the clusters.
That's one of the things
that we guarantee.
Again, we want the
state of the clusters
to match the state of the repo.
And so, with that, that's kind
of our demo of Anthos Config
Management and of Istio.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we switch back to
the slides, please.
Thanks, Ray.
Thanks for that awesome demo.
So, originally I had said that
your workflow might change.
That's actually what
I was referring to.
Instead of using
kubectl, you'll start
doing get push everywhere.
It's going to be awesome.
So thank you for that.
So we've put all
of this together.
We actually looked at this
diagram here, if you go back.
So Ray helped us see some of
the core pieces of this picture,
just from the power of
get push, which is great.
You can do this across
all your clusters.
It'll give you a lot of peace
of mind, because you'll be sure
that all your clusters
are running exactly
the posture that you want.
So going forward,
we've talked about how
to deploy these policies, how
to construct these policies,
but there's one more piece of
the puzzle, which is, how do
you keep an eye on everything?
And that's where GCP
Console and Anthos really
brings it all together
for you as an ecosystem.
You can connect all
your GKE clusters
or Anthos clusters
to GCP Console
and you can see them
all in one place.
You can see all
the details related
to that, any of your clusters,
wherever they're running.
Again, it could be on-prem, it
could be GCP, it could be AWS.
All you have to do is
log into those clusters
from GCP's console and
you'll be able to see
all the relevant details
of the control plane
in your GCP console.
As well, that goes
for stack driver.
Stack driver is
are logging tool.
You can use stack driver
to pull all the logs
from your different
clusters that you're
running across the planet and
bring them to stack driver
for analysis.
You could push them through
to BigQuery if you wanted to.
You can also use other tools.
If you're familiar with--
if you prefer Prometheus and
Grafana for graphing them,
that's also great.
And if you wanted to use
Splunk or Elastic, all of that
is supported as well.
We're close to the finish line.
So really, the three things
that we started with here
were, one, we wanted to give you
a defense in-depth experience
using this fly by wire concept
of policy based security.
That's really what
Anthos is all about.
We talked in depth about
very high resolution security
that you can get using Istio
and Kubernetes policies.
And finally, we looked at Anthos
Config Management as a way
to do git ops and put your
infrastructure as code, really
as a workflow for
CICD pipelines.
So you can actually take
all of your security posture
and replicate it
across as many clusters
as you'd like in an instant.
One final call outs to
all the other security
things that you
have to think about
as a network administrator.
We've been talking about Anthos
clusters in very high detail.
But outside the
cluster, there's a lot
of other stuff happening too.
So you have to
think about things
like your other
infrastructure pieces.
You have to think
about DDOS attacks.
about exfiltration.
You have to think about
secure access to your nodes.
So I highly encourage you to
look at all the other tools
that GCP provides
for you to ensure
that you have a security posture
that is comfortable for you.
There are some related sessions.
I know this is towards
the end of the conference.
But they'll all be
available on YouTube.
So please check them out.
They're highly related to the
content that we've covered.
And the rest of them are offered
here, below, at that link.
With that, I'd like to
thank you for your time.
I appreciate you guys staying
back on a Thursday afternoon.
Thank you for coming here and
thank you for attending Next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]